this is kind of the bridge day between
one week and the next week and this is
when we do Power Rankings in this spot i
debut them on Tuesdays at Pro Football
Talk calm and we talked about how I have
configured the 32 franchises from top to
bottom so guys let's get right to it
number one again for the I don't know
six seven straight week now the
Baltimore Ravens without question the
best team in the National Football
League
there is the Ravens and then a gap I
think to the next team and I have moved
the Saints up to number two by virtue of
that dominant performance on Monday
night over the Indianapolis Colts
Seahawks bump up 1 to number 3 49ers
fall from 2 to 4 by virtue of losing at
home to the Falcons Chiefs unchanged at
5 Packers Patriots Vikings all stay in
the same spot they were in last week 6 7
& 8 the bills back in the top 10 after
beating the Steelers and the Texans
climbed to spot number 10 from number 13
after beating the Titans in Nashville
Chris I'll let you have your first crack
at telling me how stupid my list is well
no I don't think it's that stupid I mean
especially the top 10 it's hard for me
to argue anything there that I look at
it is egregious I mean you know it's
just the Saints 49ers I guess you didn't
give any like that there was no second
thought to that it just you know it's
crazy it's a week-to-week league the
49ers beat the Saints two weeks ago I
understand that I guess the other one
I'd look at is like did you even think
about the Chiefs over the 49ers at 4 & 5
or where where are you they're like how
did you how did you go with the Chiefs
Packers Patriots I know it's the same as
last week but like what you're thinking
I'd like to hear your deep dive there I
mean the only team in that top five that
lost was the 49ers and yeah how far do
you drop them for losing at home to the
Falcons even if you are bumping the
Saints ahead of them when they had just
beaten the Saints the Saints looks so
good on Monday night I had to give the
Saints credit though so I you know I'm
not gonna drop an 11 and 3 team below a
10 and 4 team at this point in the
season and even though I've already done
it with the Packers and the Patriots
behind the Chiefs I just did not want to
put the 49ers who were 11 and 2 after
losing behind a Chiefs team that beat a
Broncos team you know it'd be different
if the cheese too
Eitan one of these other teams in the
top ten soundly or something like that
but I it just felt like the 49ers only
deserve to fall to spots but you know
what they're one and two over the last
three games they lose on Saturday night
to a desperate Rams team they can end up
one in four over their final five that's
not the way you want to go into the
postseason if you're the 49ers Peter
what are your thoughts on the top ten
Mike the two things I would do is I'd
move Kansas City up two spots and I'd
move New England down two spots because
the way I always look at these rankings
is what would happen if these two teams
played on a neutral field in Wichita
okay and so if the New England Patriots
played the Minnesota Vikings tomorrow in
Wichita Kansas
I think the Vikings are gonna win you
know and and if the Kansas City Chiefs
played Seattle or San Francisco tomorrow
on a neutral field I would like Kansas
City their defense has rebounded enough
to give me faith that they can win a
very big game now similarly I think also
your two teams at the top right now are
absolutely right Drew Brees was the
thing that was holding me back a little
bit on the Saints post thumb injury but
the last two weeks have shown me that
this is the Drew Brees of the last six
or eight years and they are going to be
a really tough out in the NFC playoffs I
will say just real quick off that Peter
I think Peters right though that Chiefs
the Chiefs of the team right now they
got the asterik next to it they just go
like watch out I mean it is it I don't
even think they're deep their offense is
hitting on all cylinders and they still
can scored like thirty in their sleep
and Peter's right their defense the way
that's playing it's been under the radar
very good the last four or five weeks I
mean they're team right now that yeah a
few weeks ago I win okay yeah they're a
playoff team I don't know what they can
really do to right now I look at them as
being the number one team to possibly
upset the Baltimore Ravens and other
than the Ravens I certainly would say
they are the favorite the second
favorite to go to the Superbowl in the
AFC you know you guys have me
reconsidering my placement of the Chiefs
at number five now when I spoke to
Patrick went home
that win over the Broncos I said to him
do you like the fact that your team has
kind of overlooked now and he said I
kind of do like it and you look at the
defense 11.2 five points per game over
the final over the last four games all
victories they are quietly building
momentum they are quietly peaking at the
right time and mahomes points to that
that stretch of adversity in the middle
of the season where they lost to the
Colts they lost to the Texans at home he
had the knee injury that knocked him out
and forced other guys to step up he said
that defense has a swagger now that it
didn't have before between guys like
Tyrann Mathieu Frank Clark and Chris
Jones you see it in practice you see it
on game day they didn't have it earlier
this year and it's all coming together
as we get closer and closer to the
playoffs and I agree with you Chris and
Peter I don't know what do you think
who's the most likely team to give the
Ravens everything they can handle in the
playoffs I think it's the Chiefs Chris
thinks it's the Chiefs do you agree I
think it's the Chiefs and I think this
is going to be one of those years where
on championship weekend we're gonna look
at the AFC championship game and say
this is probably the NFL championship
game right here it was the same way as
last year didn't we all think when maybe
not all of us but most of us think that
that the Patriots and the Chiefs that
that basically was the NFL championship
game played in the AFC and and so I
think we could see the same thing this
year yeah and with the with the Chiefs
you know it's funny how it's gone from a
presumption earlier this year that it's
Patriots Chiefs in the AFC Championship
game then it adjusted to Ravens Patriots
in the AFC championship game and now
it's settling in on this sense that
we're gonna see the Ravens and the
Chiefs get together and I really do
think the Chiefs could give the Ravens
everything they can handle I am still
intrigued by what Bill Belichick could
do second time around against Lamar
Jackson yeah if the Patriots could could
disrupt that Ravens Chiefs AFC
championship game and it could bring his
full circle Chris back to Patriots and
Chiefs in the AFC title game yeah
definitely definitely could and I do I
that's the I mean the Patriots are the
wild-card I mean we know again I think
we know right now what the Patriots are
their offense is not gonna improve to
where we're just gonna go oh wow
got it going Brady's gonna throw for
three or four touchdowns every game now
no but I do think their offense will get
better as they go along here to be more
serviceable than it has been and then
you're right the wild card I mean you
know Mike you hear me talk about game
plans specific game planning every week
there's the master of that as Bill
Belichick I mean there's there's nobody
better that's the reason they're
dominating the second decade of the 21st
century here and yeah that's the wild
card is what would bill what can bill do
thinking outside the box do once again
maybe stop the chiefs if he needs to and
the ravens and and that's what's scary
about the Baltimore Ravens in that
matchup but they have to play the
Patriots it's not gonna be the same
there's gonna be a different plan of
attack all right let's take a quick look
at the second ten at number 11 the
Titans who fell two spots after losing
at home the detections the Pittsburgh
Steelers down to 212 after losing at
home to the Buffalo Bills Cowboys jump
up five spots after handling the LA Rams
a game that few thought the Cowboys
would win especially as easily as they
did Eagles up to to number 14 bucks at
number 15 holding steady I dropped the
Rams from 11 down to number 16 after
that shellacking in Dallas Bears dropped
3 to 17 falcons up 6 to 18 after beating
49ers Browns down 2 to 19 Broncos down 1
to 20 Peter any thoughts on spots number
11 through 20 yeah I am moving the
Cowboys up to number 11 and I'm moving
the Tampa Bay Buccaneers up to 12 and I
know the Bucs are gonna have a bunch of
receivers you've never heard of now with
Evans and you know and Godwin both gone
but to me this is the dawn of the we got
to keep Jameis Winston era and how many
points can he put up every week the good
thing about the Tampa Bay Buccaneers
right now is that they didn't use this
as some sort of you know wasted end of
the season where people don't care you
know I talked to Winston after the game
on Sunday Mike and one of the things he
said is that Clyde Christian send the
quarterback coach there has basically
preached to them since they were lousy
listen
forget what the record is forget
anything other than we got to win this
Sunday and at the end of the year we'll
look at our record forget the record
right now we don't care just go every
week and try to win that particular game
and I know that that's elementary but I
think it's also easy when you're out of
it to say oh my god what was us and the
Bucks have not done that the Bucks have
used this as sort of your primer for
2020 they will keep Jameis Winston I
believe and they will go into 2020 as I
think as a as a good shot to be a
wild-card team and one other thing when
you do rankings like this I think it's
easy to look at records and say ah you
know 7 & 7 they can't be that good just
look at the way this team has played
recently and Tampa Bay is a tough tough
game for anybody in the NFL right now
yeah they are they're dangerous and when
Jameis Winston is just you know playing
the way he is right now they're they're
really dangerous because as we see when
his good is good it's great I mean it is
it's superstar great when he's on fire
like this and I agree with you they're a
dangerous football team they're gonna be
missing their top two receivers this
week so that's gonna hurt them a little
bit I mean this is the other thing I
want to say because I'm kind of with you
Peter with the Cowboys you know I
understand the Titans and the Steelers
got better records been more consistent
but Mike they're you're 11 through 20 I
just I just find it interesting like the
Cowboys are the one team I look there
that I go I still think they have Super
Bowl potential I do I mean just because
they're so talented and if they can get
hot and like we saw when everything kind
of like comes to a pinnacle like it did
last week against the Rams you can see
how dominant they can be I mean there's
a lot of me that just goes they're
really good can beat you know the Texans
the bills the Vikings the Patriots the
Packers like they they can be in that
group you know I'm not saying you're
wrong to put them at 13 right now but I
just think it's they're one of the few
teams after the top five that I look at
and go I wouldn't be shocked if they got
to the Super Bowl they have that
potential like the Steelers can upset
some people in the AFC playoffs I think
they have no chance of going to the
Super Bowl zero but the Cowboys is a
team I go oh yeah they get hot watch out
they could do it maybe the Cowboys need
to screw up the coin toss every week and
kick the opening kickoff out of bounds
that's exactly what they did against the
Rams and it's still all worked out and
they won that game easily let me say
this about the Buccaneers yeah I hadn't
realized they had won four in a row they
were three and seven they're now seven
and seven they've scored nearly 30
points at least points every week
yeah they had 28 in one of the games
every other game they've been plus 30
and the stat that that I didn't believe
when I saw it the other day Jameis
Winston the first player in NFL history
to have back-to-back regular season
games of 450 or more passing yards no
one had ever done that before
and that's true Drew Brees did in the
playoffs in 2011 but Jameis Winston is
the first one to ever do it in the
regular season and isn't it amazing guys
how it's gone from oh I don't think
Jameis Winston's gonna be back to all of
a sudden it's like he's got to be back
and at some point I think that they're
gonna have to worry that if they don't
use the franchise tag somebody else is
gonna come try to take him beater yeah I
mean I'll tell you what has happened in
the last say three weeks you're exactly
right it's gone from being should we
bring Jameis Winston back we don't know
if we're gonna bring him back to now he
may not come back on only a bridge
contract he may come back on a longer
one I will say one thing though he
acknowledged to me I have to cut down on
my mistakes so to me any to any
negotiation that Jameis Winston enters
into if I'm Jason light of the Bucs I
put my arm around you and I say we love
you we're not paying you like Aaron
Rodgers you give it away too much we
love you though and we think it's gonna
get better but I think it's gonna be
really really a tough contract to do if
they do it long term
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports